there's danger to me in this as well
it's not that often in your whole life
typically that someone will come up to
you and bear their soul you have to know
them very well and people are doing that
to me all the time they do it on the
street all the time i've been very ill
for quite a long time and it's not
obvious why but i think one of the
sources was that i've i just
was overwhelmed by insight into misery
so many i saw so many people that were
so
well grateful
is part of it to me
it's very uh
affecting when that happens it's not a
trivial experience especially when it
happens thousands of times
and you know i
i'm a reasonably astute observer of
people because i had so much practice as
a clinical psychologist i can see
what's going on with people pretty
quickly if i really watch and that is my
proclivity to watch that's why i've been
able to maneuver reasonably well in
these interviews where people have tried
to skewer me so if you're if you're up
to something i can switch into clinical
mode and watch you
and i can usually figure out what you're
up to and
in any case when people approach me so i
can see reasonably deeply into them and
they usually approach me in a pretty
open manner so they're not defended but
it's it's it's a lot of emotional weight
i mean i had some somebody called me
this week he just got my number so
randomly and
and that he had become suicidal and
you know that his lack of my lectures
he'd watched a lot of them and that that
had helped him guide him through that
well i've seen a lot of that
and that's dangerous you know it's
dangerous i'm i'm not unhappy about it i
i'm not unhappy about it it's an honor
to be able to help me
really it's a
privilege and i'm thrilled that that's
what's happening but by the same token
it's a lot of
it's a lot to see i have to be very
careful to see all that and to be able
to handle it
and so and it's very dangerous because
if i make a mistake
of any sort i'm i'm i'm in so much
trouble i see the other thing that
protected me i think
with regard to the political controversy
was that because i had so many hundreds
of hours of my lectures up on youtube
already it was very difficult to
actually pillar me successfully because
virtually everything i ever said to
students was recorded and public record
and so if my those people who felt that
they were my enemies wanted to demolish
me
they could go into that vast archive of
material and find something i said that
was reprehensible that's happened to
lots of people but no one could do that
and i think the reason for that is i
never said anything reprehensible to
students
ever
and so i think the other thing that
happened was that
people came to my website because i was
so controversial and then they listened
to some of the things i said and they
thought hmm this isn't how this man is
being described what what's going on
here exactly this is ridiculous because
this is nothing like i expected
at all and it brings me to tears
regularly it's mind-boggling
because people come up to me and this is
happening wherever i go now and they say
uh they're very polite
when they come and talk to me you know
and they're always apologetic for
interrupting and so it's never it's
never
narcissistic and it's never annoying i'm
really happy to see people and they come
up to me and they say well i know you've
heard this lots of times before but i've
really i've really been putting my life
together since i've been watching your
lectures then they tell me a story about
where they were in some dark place too
much elk all too much drugs not getting
along with her father not getting along
with her mother not having a vision for
their life being nihilistic playing too
many video games they say look i've been
i've been listening to your lectures and
i've been developing a vision for my
life i've been trying to take
responsibility and i've been trying to
tell the truth and things are way better
and so that's absolutely perfect it's
it's the right way forward as far as i'm
concerned and those are people who they
took stock of themselves they said i'm
in a dark place
and i'm a dark person and here's some
things that this dark person in this
dark place could do little things that
they could actually do i'll clean up my
damn room i'll make my bed i've had
i don't know how many people have come
and told me it's so strange they said
well i started making my bed and that
made all the difference so people come
and listen to me lecture so then the
question is well who are they listening
to well in some sense they're listening
to me because there i am
but
in some sense they're not i'm the
embodiment of a
of a set of ideas just as we all are
those ideas aren't mine they're the
collective ideas of the human race in
some sense and to the degree that i can
articulate them properly for this time
and place
to the degree that i can be wise in my
generation a biblical phrase a very
astute biblical phrase i can communicate
those ideas to myself and to other
people but i don't want to be mistaken
for their source i'm not their source
and i'm very aware of that and i
i do what i can to
make that clear to myself and my family
helps me out with that a lot they
understand the danger as well and